Republican women straight up have no
misgivings about who they are that's
very attractive to me I've decided this
and I've decided recently Republican
chicks the hottest chicks period there I
said it dude oh he said it
too low
they are though they're the hottest
chicks and I was like why I started
thinking about this I'm like why are
Republican like women so gangster hot
you know and I'm just saying look and
dude you can't be mad at me you can't be
mad at me because it's just nature you
know what I'm saying but when I see a
republican woman and she's just you know
hey [__] off I mean you can't be too
right you can't be like I got my guns
here at Costco and [__] with a Q Anon
hat you can't be like that then you're
Bonkers but dude a republican you know
who the [__] you are that's gangster and
that's hot